[Applause]
thank you so much for having me on leo
we have rocked this whole season
together yes this is gonna be
good this is gonna be so much fun
thelma we're so excited and we know that
you have a knack for making delicious
drinks which is a real art form like it
is
chef level and you created a mocktail
just for us we're so excited what are we
gonna make
this is completely inspired by you
and we're going to call it
the honey drew barrymore
and then some berries raspberries
and meat and i have a special glass for
you
that is the coolest class i've ever seen
and i
have the mint with the berry and another
little daisy
and this is all inspired by you and we
also have some agave
okay so one thing that i have to say
that it's important about this
is that it's full of vitamin c yes
antioxidants and you know what else this
has
this helps promote collagen
oh that's also very hydrating
oh my gosh can i drink this every day
all day long
i know i know it's perfect for the
summer but you can drink it all day long
so this is my original honey
drew barrymore let's go thank you thank
you so much okay
we are your little students and we will
follow you
okay i'm sorry i used my hands i washed
them so we put some with the honey drew
okay and then we're gonna put some
berries
and i'm going to put some more because
it's very more
more berries we put a little bit of ice
i'm sorry i don't measure things i'm a
messy cooker
just oh i am i am like a chicken with
its head cut off in this kitchen but
that's how i roll
we put the mint leaves you can go don't
put the stick
that holds them just the mint leaves and
then we can put a little bit of water
and some and then we're going to put
some ice so it's like a smoothie
that's what we do in this kitchen we
just have fun
and then should we put the agave in oh
thank you thank you thank you thank you
by the way
you know the drink better than me here
we go
okay ready
[Applause]
here we go it comes out kind of like a
smoothie
this is oh my god this smells so good
thank you
thank you thank you drew you are so all
right you got it
i'm not the best at pouring but i'll try
my
[Applause]
it's best i mean at least we've got a
little bit
oh and you know what let's do a little
refreshment for garnish
yes we gotta make it every time i put a
garnish on i'm like
that looks so much more kind of like a
strawberry milkshake
exactly it looks like a milkshake a
smoothie
oh my gosh leo it's amazing i'm not
trying this i'm tired
so if you say it's good it's probably
really good it's so
good cheers cheers to you
selma
um i just thank you both so much go to
the drewbermart show.com to get salma
hayek's original recipe
for the honey drew barrymore smoothie
and
the hitman's wife's bodyguard where some
kayak
rocks all of her own stunts and proves
what is possible
and a way to just celebrate your legacy
is out in theaters now
selma hayek i don't think the term girl
crush has anything
on how i feel for you thank you so much
thank you the hitman wife's bodyguards
out in theaters right now
[Music]